take a seat please
welcome to this extraordinary meeting of
risk and assurance
um
we have
bruce
zooming from wellington
and everybody
he's asked that i chair this meeting
this because uh i am present and it's a
little more difficult for him
uh to do so
firstly
i believe we have a quorum are there any
apologies
uh councillor arnold
and
councillor crackit is a councillor
pottinger
and councillor crackit is joining us by
zoom
my colleague jeff as well perhaps an
apology for jeff grant
we'll have someone move those apologies
thank you councillor soper secretary
councillor clark thank you all those in
favor please say aye aye against
abstentions carried can i just check is
this a meeting where
non-members are allowed to vote
on risk and insurance i presumed on this
one it was but i i think for the purpose
mr chair that in fact is your call if
you wish to have non-members
um able to speak and or vote
um certainly non-members should
certainly be able to speak
ultimately through hiv this is only a
recommendation we only make a
recommendation to council we can cannot
make a um any final determination so i'd
be comfortable and
for that purpose you concur bruce
you're so encouraging
right i think
we have one major light
latex item for the agenda which will be
received in public
excluded don't believe there are any
other
accepted thank you council ludlow
second councillor madison thank you guys
in favor please say hi
against abstentions carried thank you
there are no changes could i then please
ask that we move to public excluded with
the exemption exception
of
lindsay mckenzie and also note that mary
jane thomas from pr law is here and will
attend the meeting also
someone please move thank you darren
thank you
you